et amos qu'on retrouve julian calling
bonjour julian pour les russes la ligne
rouge c'est donc l'ukraine rejoigne
l'otan
oui bien sûr et vladimir poutine
derrière c'était assez intéressant de
noter a été beaucoup plus ferme en fait
récemment dans cette prise de parole
publique sur ces sujets notamment pour
donner la position de la russie de
manière beaucoup plus claire qu'avant et
également dire ce que la russie
attendait des pays occidentaux
etats-unis des états unis bien sûr en
particulier alors la ligne rouge absolue
bien sûr vous disiez c'est évidemment
l'adhésion potentiel de l'ukraine et
dans une moindre mesure la géorgie
également à l'otan mais plus
spécifiquement encore vladimir poutine a
déclaré récemment qu'il ne souhaitait
pas que que l'occident et que les états
unis installe plus de systèmes
militaires sur le sol ukrainien en
faisant par exemple référence à la
roumanie un exemple où il a également
déjà des missiles américains par exemple
qui sont déjà en place sur le territoire
roumain donc et pour lui en fait il est
il explique que du point de vue russe ce
serait avoir vraiment des missiles à
apporter direct de la russie et moscou
serait sous la menace extrêmement rapide
d'une attaque potentielle donc ça c'est
évidemment absolument intolérable pour
un prêt du point de vue du kremlin est
donc selon lui également l'envoi de
nouvelles troupes à la frontière vous
disiez et vu plutôt de manière
préventive par les experts et par les
observateurs ici à moscou il ne s'agit
pas évidemment pour eux c'est dans 10 et
leur discours en tout cas tant dahir
vraiment l'ukraine ou en tout cas l'est
l'ukraine et plus tôt encore une fois de
faire ça de manière préventive pour
éviter toute escalade également du côté
occidental est en tout cas voilà la
russie souhaite montrer a visiblement
qu'elle n'est plus vraiment en train de
bluffer qu'elle est prête à prendre une
option militaire plus forte si l'otan
quand une fois états unis collaborent de
manière plus directe avec l'ukraine et
la russie pour finir également on peut
préciser que la russie fait le constat
que les accords de minsk qui sont censés
régler la situation dans le donbass sont
plus ou moins mort et enterré qu'on n'a
plus d'espoir que ces accords sont mis
en place et donc c'est pour ça que la
russie encore une fois soit passé on
peut dire un peu à au stade supérieur et
monte un peu les enjeux et voilà
provoqué ce ce dialogue plus ferme avec
les états unis voilà la rencontre
virtuelle byden poutine est à suivre sur
france 24 à partir de 16h merci beaucoup
de julian pour ses commentaires depuis
moscou